since 1953 the government has been
conducting a top-secret mind control
program to create super soldiers these
sleeper agents were among us waiting to
be activated they could be your friend
your family or the person you least
expect chariot progressive listen
Mandelbrot set is in motion echo with
the cherry of suspicion cherry does that
only recruit something do you want your
soup
hey stop stop doing stuff to my car had
guns and knives and they were being like
total dicks shoved it through this guy
why are people Jorah stabbed you know
but I like freaking out I have a lot of
anxiety about this that would've hurt
agent hell has been activated
he killed two operatives with a spoon
what walk it down what if I'm like a
robot how do you feel I feel kind of
amazing so acid House confirms on-site
your own strike is a go
whoo we get to Attack Position hey rose
I think I could probably break this lock
that's cold
the old frying pan Electric whoa
just
oh man come on
just give us like
make Sapna I have to go to work hey Jung
ho ho go to TV yet again Madame Lafleur
katatak but you liquidy the edge of how
minutes